wonderful my foods gonna be in rainbow
now TV news I'm scrolling through
Instagram when I see this crazy unicorn
Pizza being posted everywhere so I click
on it and it's right here in New York
City it's this place called industry
kitchen they're calling it pop Candyland
pizza but the Internet's calling it
unicorn pizza so I'm going with that I
want it I'm gonna go get it I'm gonna
see if my coworker Angie it wants to go
with me hey Jay
do you want to go eat some unicorn pizza
I love unicorns and I love pizza
that sounds interesting let's go all
right guys so we're just going up we
just got to an industry kitchen we're
here to get the uniform pizzas
I'm ready to Instagram it let's do it
yes believe it it sounds like something
I think so oh my god this thing looks
amazing it's so loud you can hear the
pop rock I didn't know that pop rocks do
something in like heat yeah I didn't
know it did anything and I was like
waiting for it to get in my mouth but I
guess not you can see it rainbow crust
cream cheese candy cotton candy with pop
rock let's go for it let's just excited
about this and I'm hungry as hell I
guess I got to get some of this huh oh
yeah yeah definitely I feel like a child
I do I feel like I am a kid I like this
more than I thought I would cuz it's not
as sweet as I thought it would be
yeah like the cream cheese on top of the
dough it kind of reminds me of red
velvet cake and I really like looking at
it I think I want to keep you in and
just but it looks so pretty and the
piece of crust neutralizes the sweetness
temporarily so you're like I could eat
more and then you like eat more and
you're like no and then you have some
more pizza bread and you're like I could
eat more we're also being like stared
down by some children who are like
glaring at us we're having this pupa
you grow up so you don't have to act
like an adult it is just orienting to
have pop rocks while you're eating
normal food kind of feel the different
parties popping off in different areas
of your mouth in all at different times
and it's like whoa oh and even know
there's a pop pop pop rock up here this
was also put in a wood fire oven so
that's pretty cool you can taste a
little bit of the of the smokiness
there's so many things on Instagram are
so pretty but you get them and they're
like this tastes like fine this tastes
great we got it we have to share the
love that's good this is official time
when we can really call ourselves big
kids yeah you want a pizza that tastes
like a carnival that's the pizza to go
[Music]
this diam polish I go you got him you
need a member